so this is i think rogan talking about
uh owen you're an ambassador for your
cause
when you speak i'm and let me tell you
something a lot there's eliza
schlesinger's on she's actually pretty
she's a hot chick right
why is she dressed down like she's about
to paint somebody's house um
i mean she was she she's been hot but i
mean she's also good
she's hot yeah really into the
environment and plastic and stuff like
that and i
am very specific about how and when i
post about things because you don't want
people to get activism fatigue
and you don't want to be the person who
posts about everything because then no
one will listen to anything
right and you don't you know why might i
listen to you anyway don't want to
call people out specifically because
just because somebody
carried a plastic bottle that day
doesn't mean they don't drive she's
doing this now
for so long she got [ __ ] for basically
only being known for her looks
i think this is that's why she's doing
this like i think she's trying to be
like
because remember there was a couple
years there where she was all dolled up
trying you know what i mean and
everybody was like
like i remember there was a you go back
and listen to the old o a episodes and
they're all titled like the ones with
patrice all have like one of his
funniest lines from the episode
is always the title there's a patrice on
a episode called
from eliza schlesinger because he was
making a joke about
how she got ahead and stuff so i think
that's why um
you know she's kind of dressing down uh
somebody goes oh she's not hot okay
maybe she was hot we come on now
we're not gonna pretend like she wasn't
hot right
i can't i mean you could i mean you
could think she's a complete utter idiot
but
does her that's that's not yeah i'm
sorry that's not a hot chick
yeah come on man let's be realistic here
let's not be [ __ ]
you know what i mean there's some people
just try hard trying to be like [ __ ]
she's not that cute like okay whatever
she's hot you'd leave her sitting at a
bar on a thursday night no
no i gotta get back i got work in the
morning people are doing right did you
see chris practice yeah
that's literally what i'm thinking of
and while i love that he did that part
of him oh did you see that chris pratt
getting shamed
another a new one yeah chris pratt so
chris pratt took a picture
for one of his um from fitness equipment
or something that he's that he's
for a magazine or some [ __ ] and he was
you know just finished working out and
chris pratt's holding like a plastic
bottle
jason momoa aquaman i did see that it
was all like hey chris
i don't mean to blah blah blah brother
but you should be using renewable it's
like dude [ __ ] you bro leave him alone
like
are you [ __ ] serious right now
by the way and if you know of these
people where if this jason mamoe
actually cared and he was his friend
he would have called him and said hey
man you know maybe you should use but
instead he just did it publicly
virtually put him on [ __ ] classic
virtue signal and just [ __ ] on him for
no reason
he's like that's a little holier than
that who shamed him jason momoa is so
[ __ ] hot he's so hot
he's not but we we're so especially
online we're so quick to be like you're
not doing it right we do it with friends
too and you have no idea right the pious
good life that person is leading
and you're judging them on a snapshot on
which you don't want to be judged on
well they want to judge people the thing
is about it's a lot of what this is
about people that are on the fringes
it's the ideas are great
right but the people that want attention
for espousing these great ideas
oftentimes are the fringe so the far
left and the far right
a lot of it what it is it's just people
that are
ultra aggressive about enforcing their
ideology and then they're really shitty
and they want other people to comply
and so you get these people that
represent the right and these people
that represent the left but
a lot of the ideas of the right and the
level there's nothing wrong with being
fiscally conservative there's nothing
wrong with being a true republican
is right uh and you want less government
in your money
well a true comedian is a man so you
know whatever
shut up you [ __ ] dick there's room in
there for conversation but when you go
far right and then you go far left then
there's no room
and when you start vilifying people yeah
from the get-go
uh and when you start expecting people i
owen benjamin who is look at
look at rogan's face he doesn't want him
brought up he doesn't want him brought
up because he's had owen on his show
and he doesn't want another four months
of him going joe rogan's a toe
eliza schlesinger is a [ __ ]
joe is a toe he doesn't want five more
months of this so he's like
um i'm i almost hear the curve your
enthusiasm music is
joe is like please don't say his name
because it's gonna be
in six months from the get-go uh here we
go and when you start expecting people i
owen benjamin who is just basically like
in a tin foil hat somewhere
and like living off the grid he offended
a lot of people
right you're staring at me yeah
even she noticed like did i i did
something didn't i
she it got awkward this is great
uh and he said a bunch of stuff about
stuff and
i remember there was this girl that i
was
friends with on social media didn't know
her but just followed her because i
liked her writing
that's it and she dm's me one day and
she's like
she's like oh and benjamin like how
could you be like maybe i
i don't know if i'd interact with him on
twitter i'm never on twitter because i
think it's a toxic [ __ ] hole
uh and she was like she's getting mad at
me and i go what are you talking about
she was like he said all this stuff
that's anti
and i hadn't heard anything so wait wait
wait wait i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i can't believe i'm
going to have to do this we're going to
have to side with owen
out of everything that owen benjamin has
done
the track kids thing you're going to
draw stuff
calling [ __ ] it doc [ __ ] it doxxing
people
fake try sending murder my children the
earth is flat dinosaurs aren't real
it bothers you it's the trap stuff
not can i point out too she's she's
doing this thing
she's doing this thing that they do on
that side of the [ __ ] aisle
where she's go oh can you believe he's
anti
no no no no no he was specifically
against
trash children that was his big that's
his big
claim to fame and he wasn't he i'm not
giving owen the [ __ ] you know the big
old salute like he was alone
in that you know peterson did it a lot
of people were like rogan
rogan himself has said they're children
they shouldn't be
so she see other she's she's twisted
you're gonna make us [ __ ] side with
owen
out of everything that owen said that's
the thing
i didn't want to side with owen here
well let me let me say what he said
okay and here's the thing he went off
into a spiral right
but i agree with what he said
what he said was there was someone that
he knew
someone who works in hollywood that had
a three-year-old
that they were turning right and he said
that that was child abuse that was what
led
i don't disagree with that crazy
situation
i got i got hey rogan gotta give and he
has
rogan has no reason
in the world to even involve himself in
this quagmire
oh and benjamin to speak of him or
anything
jesus man i gotta give it to you gotta
give joe credit here
i i gotta grieve i'm giving him credit
he could have just been like yeah he's
crazy in the woods this is the weirdest
babyface turn ever right
this is this this is like when uh this
is like when uh
uh triple h and uh randy orton and
everybody were just kicking the [ __ ] out
of daniel bryan and the shield game out
this just kicked the [ __ ] out of triple
h it was the weird it was the most
like you didn't see it coming and all of
a sudden they were just baby faces this
is the weirdest babyface turn ever this
is this is um this is funny too
because he not only is he saying that
but didn't she just say two seconds ago
i don't really judge people like one or
two things they say and now she's
completely judging
owen benjamin on the track thing on a on
an incorrectly
presented one thing two on top of it
this is i no i agree with it by her own
admission via hearsay
because she said yes somebody said have
you heard owen benjamin's auntie
and i was like oh no and then she just
left it at that like so
it's i don't judge people based on just
one or two things
but i did hear one thing through hearsay
and it's wrong and i'm going to judge
owen benjamin based on it
i don't disagree with that yeah i agree
with you it's a child 100 percent you
wouldn't let that child decide what it's
eating
right so that's something that's a great
joke you don't let i
always say this i wish i could remember
who it was they said you don't let a kid
pick their outfit
why the [ __ ] would you let them pick
their just like the joke i just made
yeah but it's somebody did it already
right i'm not gonna do the joke
uh but so that aside and the spiral side
which i didn't even
participate like it's whatever like
those are your choices that's what
you're saying i had known but
here's the thing that cost him dearly
his agency left him
and then comedy clubs banned him for
that that was the beginning
he just steered into that skid well
that's but that's what started the skid
right what started the there was
something else about like
he called someone who had written a look
that's that's not the point of whatever
things went south afterwards you have to
manage those things
my point was i knew none of this so i'm
just like going to brunch one day
and this person starts attacking me
offline
how can you be friends with him and i go
whoa what are you talking about she's
like he's saying all these horrible
things and i
attack you in person she's uh in my like
direct message oh and
this is my only point is i said i've
known owen
most of my career let me go read what
you're talking about
and she was angry at me for wanting to
gather information
this person is a writer who i literally
until that moment didn't know was
because i was just a fan based on merit
like i just like the writing
oh you're so holy you're so pie you're
so much better than everybody shut up
and i said how dare you shame on you
as a journalist you should applaud that
i go and collect my facts
they want compliance like immediate
instantaneous competition and i said i'm
an ally and i am pro-trans and i am
pro-gay rights but you do not get to
bark at me
on a sunday morning when i have no idea
what we're talking about and get mad at
me
i'm sorry i don't trust anyone who says
they're an ally about anything i'm a
total but you say that if you say i'm an
ally
what's going on today he's being i feel
awkward what's happening
this is getting weird bro i'll tell you
what's happening bernie sanders isn't in
the studio
that's what's happening that's true yeah
eddie bravo and uh
you know brendan schaav aren't in the
studio
not buying it he's giving her nothing
he's giving her nothing i kind of like
joe here i gotta let joe's coming off
[ __ ] i thought they were this was
gonna turn into a bash festival
no it's not ah [ __ ] joe's being kind
of based right now
yeah i don't buy it i vote it's mrs
doubtfire that's all
over now she is just internal allies
gross
it's okay when other people use it like
he's an ally that guy's an ally she's an
ally i get that that's a good way to use
it but when you say i'm an ally i'm like
okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] orifice says uh uh rogan's
getting
tired you gotta eat it's gotta be
exhausting exhausting up there you just
like
you gotta do all these shows and you're
just like yeah i don't know i don't care
i don't care anymore i'm pro trans good
for you
and i blocked that person real [ __ ]
what's
going on i don't know but i'm enjoying
it whatever this is i'm enjoying it
mark at me and tell me for any cause
yeah i too many [ __ ] people live on
twitter
it's not good it's not healthy folks i
don't even have to talk to people
twitter is it's becoming like a subway
bathroom wall like people the show
wolf told me the exact same thing last
week she doesn't have it on her phone
that's the second time he's called her
out for saying something somebody else
said yep
like very subtly yeah yeah michelle wolf
said that last week
because you're just screaming into a
void and all it does is just
it just nets negativity so they're just
waiting for you to [ __ ] up
by the way anybody who's ever said
anything awful to me on twitter
who i've seen in person they say nothing
and i'm
you know i'm that's the only way people
should talk is face to face
yeah louis ck said that to me we were
talking about this and he said it's just
talk but it's written down
so people think it's like more than it
is well because people but people would
say these kind of things and you would
go ah
you get like she said and retweets which
are basically pitchforks but like if you
said something like uh
if you said something about someone like
you said something about bert or
something like that
you know and he said it online like
[ __ ] bert should know a lot about
getting drunk in russia if he's if he
read that it sounds so bad yeah it's
like what the [ __ ] well because
there's no inflection right right but if
you just said it to me
we were hanging out and then you saw
burton hugged him i wouldn't think
you're a hypocrite
right right right so it's it's like what
louis was saying it's just
talk it's but it's but it's written it's
talk without nuance or inflection
because not everyone has mastered
grammar or punctuation that's worse
especially for us because we say things
we talk [ __ ]
you know like even now yeah would you
ever master taking the [ __ ] stain out of
your [ __ ] cap
oh uh what is that you and i are
agreeing on everything and i'm like i'm
gonna face a firing squad
of betas when i get on my instagram
and rogan was talking and not you listen
there's a certain percentage of people
that are going to tackle are you ever
snapped
are you a [ __ ] i mean we we get it
that's the uh
joe's having none of her nonsense today
yeah man i i did not
i did not ex dude i did not expect that